the vikings valhalla is a game of
thrones for a new era specifically the
throne of england he has everything you
need to know about the end of the
beginning for this new saga of vikings
the beginning of the end of vikings
valhalla lies in king canute's decision
to stay in england and rule over the
conquered kingdom that decision kicks
off a chain of events that end in mass
death and destruction his supposed ally
king olaf of norway harbours ambitions
of uniting his country under the banner
of christianity and that means
overthrowing the free city of katagat
olaf knows that canoe dreams of creating
a great northern empire that stretches
across the top of europe and would never
allow him to take control of cataget an
important trading post and the real seat
of power in norway with canoes across
the sea and smitten with the widow of
england's king athol red olof decides to
pay his friend's wife a visit that's
right knut was already married to queen
elefighu when he set sail for england
sensing an opportunity olaf drops in on
aylefagoo and tells her exactly what has
been going on hoping to talk her into
lending him knute's fleet the queen ends
up making her own play after learning
from olaf that her husband was busy
romancing the beautiful emma of normandy
she scoops up their kids and set sail
for england with the fleet in tow
intending to take her place as in her
opinion it's rightful queen when she
arrives she discovers that canoe left to
deal with an uprising and he married
emma before he set sail
knuts captured england by goading the
young king edmund son of the late king
athelred into a rash decision edmund led
a charge across london's prize bridge
after being called a coward but he rode
straight into a trap the bridge was
brought down behind him stranding the
english king prince harold of norway
wanted to take his head when he found
out that athol red was already dead but
knuts kept edmund alive to act as a
go-between with the english nobles you
have the support of the innocus which is
important to me
and will be your job to manage
as long as you do it well we'll get
along fine with the boy king under his
wing and his marriage to emma of
normandy the great granddaughter of
rollo complete knut was in good shape
but the arrangement didn't work for
queen elefigu with knutsgon his father
the fearsome swain forkbeard came to
england to rule in his place
to help him in his quest to take katagat
king olaf calls on the christians alert
korra a murderous yard who hates pagans
when we get his backstory it's clear why
korag comes from a pagan family who put
forward one of their sons to be
sacrificed to the gods seeing his older
brother get his throat cut changed the
young korah who turned to christ he's
been on a mission to cleanse the viking
world of pagans and nowhere is off
limits in a shocking turn of events
yalkora gains entrance to ub salah and
proceeds to massacre the priests for
maximum intimidation yal korra
decapitates the priests and hangs their
heads from the mast of a ship that he
then sends floating towards katagat his
men kill almost everyone in uppsala
leaving only a few children alive to
pass on a message to freydis eric
stutter kyra became fascinated with
freydis after finding out that she saw
the seer and he wants her dead he's
convinced that he is the subject of the
oracle's visions of the future not
freidus it is i who is the cross that
carries the sword not this girl you
prophesied olaf thinks he's crazy and
he's probably right but he secures him
as an ally anyway
freitas eric stutter got the chance to
visit uppsala before yalkora burned it
to the ground which was a huge moment
for her as a greenlander freydis still
follows the old gods she arrives in
katagat at the beginning of vikings
valhalla not to answer the call of king
knuds but to find and kill a christian
viking who raped her it turns out her
attacker is an important man in
kingolof's inner circle but she kills
him anyway putting her at the mercy of
yal hokken leader of katagat despite
olaf's protests freydis has given the
benefit of the doubt seeing that she was
within her rights to take revenge under
greenland's law she's ordered to remain
in category though hokun allows freydis
to visit ubsala where she encounters
sasir the supernatural oracle tells
freydis that she is the last but she has
no idea what that means she only begins
to understand the gravity of it when
hokum reveals to her that she has
dreamed about a terrible disaster
striking katagat she sees the waves
receding revealing a bounty of fish for
the people only to come back as a wall
of water in hoken's stream a tsunami
smashes into katagat and leaves just one
survivor for the longest time she
believed that survivor was her but after
hearing what the sia told freydis she's
convinced that the greenlander is
actually the prophesised last daughter
of ubsala and has heard she's been
dreaming about you are the last
[Music]
the last daughter of absalom
we know from the sagas that leif erikson
was a famous viking in his own right but
when we're introduced to him in vikings
valhalla he's best known as the son of
eric the red he goes to england and
steps out of his father's shadow and
style bringing down london bridge but
it's not without cast the pagan
greenlander begins to experience a
crisis of faith after nearly being
killed in an ambush a local girl puts a
cross in his hand he survives and he
can't help but wonder if it was jesus
who saved him his christian comrade
prince harold calls it a miracle by the
time leif returns to norway he's clearly
having doubts about the old ways
low-ranking saxon godwin is a savvy
social climber he let prince harold
escape during the same bryce's day
massacre which paid off for him when the
vikings came to take their revenge he
ends up becoming an advisor to king
canutes though he's still loyal to the
english king young edmund at least to
begin with when knut is called away and
his father swain forkbeard is suddenly
calling the shots things quickly change
edmund can't stand fogbeard even calling
him an abomination in a private moment
with godwin that champ's comment leads
the reveal of a conspiracy
how much do you hate it
your sentiments are not felt in
isolation your highness godwin has
convinced the english nobles to back
edmund but something happens that makes
him reconsider his options forkbeard
kills the eldermen of wessex and
believing him to be trustworthy he makes
godwin the first earl of wessex all of a
sudden his admins like godwin needs out
of the picture not forkbeard godwin uses
a hidden robe to bring edmund off his
horse and when his injuries aren't quite
severe enough to kill him he stabs him
in the heart for good measure it appears
as though he's gotten away with murder
though queen emma notices the wound and
sees right through him vogby had
ultimately stepped in on his behalf but
emma isn't likely to forget the murder
of her late husband's son in a hurry
godwin will need to watch his back in
season two
with yal korra and his warriors allying
with olaf his chances of taking katagats
and becoming the undisputed king of
norway seem high harold who is currently
undercover for hokken forces korra into
offering a palais by playing on the
zealot's own christianity he tells quran
that their lord does not look kindly on
those who deny entry to the kingdom of
heaven to those who seek it they should
at least ask the pagans to convert
before massacring them korra agrees
begrudgingly of course harold knows full
well that yal hokum would never agree to
a mass christian conversion in the
proudly multi-faith cutter gat but the
brief parlay gives him time to pass a
secret message to leif with a hand
signal and some clever wording he
informs him that kora will attack by
land while olaf will come from the sea
using the hide tide of the wolf moon to
bypass the defenses trebuchets are
brought to the ford and qatagat's forces
are split in two but what harold doesn't
know is that his dvs half-brother has
tricked both him and kora knowing that
harold would share the plan with katagat
olof sent a bunch of empty ships
floating towards the city his real
intentions was to let the armies of yao
hokan and yalkora destroy each other
before swooping in to pick up the pieces
with olaf secretly waiting in the wings
the forces of yalkova descend on katagat
the crazed christian viking as for no
payment for his services instead he
tells olaf that god
has instructed me
to build a great church
in catechute his lord wants him to make
it so tall that it touches the sky
koval's berserkers are relentless as
they scale the walls and enter the city
but so are hawkins shield maidens who
managed to get her to safety after she's
hit with numerous arrows she isn't fated
to survive but before she goes to
valhalla she reminds freidis that she's
the last daughter of uppsala and must
live freydis won't abandon category
without settling her score first however
the big showdown between freydis and
korra is teased throughout the first
season of vikings valhalla and it
doesn't disappoint freydis has given a
sword by the priests of ube salad during
her visit and she's almost struck down
with it kyra disarms her but he doesn't
act quickly enough freydis pounces and
stabs him with a dagger before
retrieving her sword that's when she
utters some very potent parting words to
him cross that carries the sword was
never you
she makes it clear that it was always
her destiny to possess the legendary
weapon kara's last word is no as freyjas
brings her blade down decapitating him
as he had done to so many at uppsala
with both yar hokan and yal kora out of
the way taking katagat is relatively
easy for olaf he and his men storm the
city and make their way to the great
hall killing any stragglers who stand in
their way in a move that he will no
doubt come to regret in coming seasons
olaf slays the greenlander live the only
person keeping leif erikson on the
straight and narrow the son of eric the
red had opened up to live telling her
all about his traumatic childhood and
how his father controlled greenland
through fear he once saw him beat a man
until he couldn't walk because the lamp
he owed him had not been born yet that
same darkness lives inside leif he says
and he only feels calm and content when
he's with liv liv's death is crushing
for life who instantly regrets not being
able to comfort her more in her final
moments liv tries to calm lathe by
telling him that she will meet him again
in valhalla but she dies before he can
answer when his morning is interrupted
by a group of men he snaps they barely
even notice lathe hunched next to liv's
body as they burst into the barney's in
but they've chosen the wrong viking to
mess with by the time he's done with
them he's covered in so much blood that
you could call him leif the red
as viewers we aren't entirely sure which
side harold sigurdsson is on leading up
to the battle for katagat but he proves
himself loyal to the city and to freidus
harold declares his love to the pagan
shield maiden from greenland before he
secretly goes undercover in olof's camp
and when freyja spots him wounded on the
ground she follows her heart and saves
him with the city lost the two flee
qatar got on horseback and lived to
fight another day they finished the
season together but how long their
relationship will last us up for debate
their vastly different outlooks and
religion could well drive a wedge
between them going forward when the
christian prince dismisses a comment
about life being fated the staunchly
pagan freydis says that loving him is
sometimes hard a word that harold is
associated with to this day the viking
saga tell us that harold sigurdsson went
on to become the king known as herald
harada meaning harold hard ruler olaf's
forces flee from katagat when swain
forkbeard arrives with his son's fleet
and he's clearly going to be in canute's
bad bugs for a while if he manages to
keep his head
that means harold will likely be crowned
king of norway and vikings valhalla
season 2 but he doesn't seem like the
iron fisted type just yet perhaps
heartbreak will turn him into the hard
ruler history remembers him as
we can also expect to see the children
of eric the red inching closer to their
destinies and vikings valhalla season 2.
leif erikson is popularly known as one
of the first europeans to set foot on
north american soil having landed in
present-day canada around 500 years
before christopher columbus set sail
according to the saga of the
greenlanders they've heard about a new
land with a milder climate from an
icelandic trader this trader caught a
glimpse of the lush woodlands and vast
mountains from a distance but didn't go
ashore lave sets out to do just that and
he would end up making several stops
along the atlantic coast eventually
setting up a camp in a place he called
finland because of the abundance of
grapes laith wasn't the only child of
eric the red to make the trip to the new
world either freydis is also said to
have sailed to north america and she
apparently stayed there for a lot longer
lathe wintered in finland but his sister
was away for three years she helped
create a settlement in finland where the
greenlanders coexisted peacefully with
the native americans for some time
tensions eventually spilled into
conflict however and according to the
saga of eric the red freidis went into
battle while heavily pregnant while
norsemen have already set foot in
america and the vikings universe we
still expect lathe to make the journey
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies and tv shows are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]